[Music]
patrice o'neil had a documentary i hope
a lot of you guys had the opportunity to
see it it was
[ __ ] uh it was brilliant all things
comedy put together unfortunately it was
on comedy central
and um that's not all things comedy's
fault i actually reached out to them and
i reach out to netflix and i go
what the [ __ ] were you guys thinking not
putting
this patrice o'neill documentary on
netflix yeah why the [ __ ] wouldn't you
guys do this yeah
and uh what my guy over at netflix what
robbie told me was
he goes that thing was sold four years
ago robbie's the biggest fan
of the world of patrice yeah and
i watch this thing and i the reason why
we're talking about this later in the
podcast by the way is because i assume
most of you haven't watched it because
it's on comedy central yeah and even if
you did watch the first area on comedy
central you missed like 14 minutes
because they were trying to fit in in a
[ __ ]
if you got youtube tv it's on demand and
it's an hour and a half which i assume
is the full yes
yeah hour and a half commercials up top
for like a minute and a half and then
it's just straight
go go watch it it is profound
it is inspiring inspiring it is
heartbreaking
heartbreaking heartbreakingly sad and i
got emotional by the end almost
[ __ ] i cry you've heard us talk about
patrice o'neill on the podcast a lot
patrice o'neill is
in my opinion the greatest comic to ever
live he's also my last comedic
inspiration
i've not been inspired comedically since
him
that's not to say that there aren't
great comics there are people who have
done things that are very funny
but i have yet to see somebody do comedy
that i thought
was a better version of what patrice did
patrice was calmly perfected in the way
that i view comedy
and he wasn't a perfect man in the terms
away like he treated people and that
kind of stuff like
he really [ __ ] pissed live people off
he was very self-sabotaging with his
career
yeah and keith robinson it was a comic
who's the [ __ ] king maker we have to
have another conversation another time
about god bless
you how many people you guys all know
just because of keith robinson yeah just
as maybe a lot but
the reason keith robinson has played a
major role in so many of the most
successful comedians in history and
of our time and people who keith
robinson keith robinson is a brilliant
comic
uh he has a special also on comedy
central so maybe you haven't seen it
it's called back of the bus back of the
bus back of the bus funny is what he's
referring to and if you ever rode the
school bus to school you know that
that's where the jokes went down at the
back of the bus right
and um thank god you clarified that
because i didn't realize the other
connotation in back of the bus
he's old not that old but uh it's a type
of funny that he
is referring to right this is what i
think that we exemplify on the show like
some people might call it the barbershop
or the back of the bus but that's where
you know you were giving out the dozens
in the back of the bus everybody was
getting
you know their balls busted if you will
and um
but he has had so many people he's he
brought kevin hart to new york
and he played he was instrumental in
having patrice come down and he used to
drive kev to from philly to new york
like multiple times
yeah he's a [ __ ] god like that guy
made everybody yeah so he's he's played
this amazing role and he's kind of like
maybe lost in the casual comedy fans
you know understanding history but um
anyway so patrice he was the last i
think
i was saying last comedic inspiration in
terms of like what he did with comedy
and how he did comedy and
he was comedy to me you know i um
i've i've tons of respect for the
different types of comedy
right but the type of comedy that i've
always tried to live up to
which is patrice o'neill's style of
comedy
um initially i got into comedy through
it was def comedy jam and then chris
rock was the guy who really started like
getting my mind working on what comedy
was um then obviously chappelle
as well you know but chris rock i was
more part of that tree and then i saw
patrice
and that's who i was like oh this is it
this is the final version yeah there's
nothing beyond this
and i have yet to see anything beyond
this and
he did comedy from feeling
what you feel is
doesn't matter if it is right or wrong
it is true
you have an argument with your girl and
she's like saying [ __ ] that's absolutely
ridiculous but
she felt it you can't tell her yeah she
ain't
feel it yeah right when you feel
something and you're talking about
something through
feeling you can be wrong yeah matter of
fact
the funniest observations of your
feelings
are things that are incredibly wrong
yeah
they're horrible yes right but they're
funny
and they're relatable and in my opinion
if you want to be one of the great great
greats
you can't be a straight joke slinger
patrice used his clever he was very
clever but oftentimes
clever is a crutch
yeah being able to say the clever thing
and then you get like an applause
break because there's this like uh
visceral
not even visceral it's like almost like
a human reaction to go oh you tricked me
bravo while it's clever it doesn't
necessarily
penetrate patrice o'neill was a
brilliantly clever guy but his
jokes were all off of feeling and the
punch lines are often not clever
but incredibly relatable or visceral
feelings right here's this one thing
where you talk about how he feels bad
for side chicks
yeah right because nobody cares about
side chicks right let me think about
side chick
i go over a house 1am [ __ ] her drink her
last snapple then leave
drink her last snapple we all are
thinking the same thing
white fridge completely empty you open
it up and there's a snapple on the top
grated metal grated thing right how the
[ __ ]
did we all have the same visual right
he he came from such a real place with
comedy that sometimes he's not even
he's not even saying the cleverest punch
line to get you to clap
you're clapping because you just got
this image right that his paint is so
clear that we're all thinking in the
same time
right right there's another joke i
remember we were watching this special
live
elephant in the room where he was just
talking about like taking the
like girls always complain about what's
in the food she said something like
ladies men are just cooler we're just
cool yeah you ever get the wrong order
with your girl she gets the wrong order
they do get her order wrong and she
freaks out they put onions on it
she and they freaking out and then use
the trump these wretched onions
and she he just does this whole meltdown
of a girl and he goes man just you see
that hey
hey you see that huh that is and he goes
and he puts it on the ground right he
goes just right there on the ground
you're just leaving on the ground
right but like this visual there's
nothing clever about it
yeah per se but it is comedy
and i'm not trying to knock clever but
it is a brilliant tool that he also used
he had tons of
little clever switches and stuff in his
comedy but his comedy always came from
feeling
there's a lot of guys who do comedy and
they're just like uber what's the
funniest joke about uber
i don't care if i don't feel that way
about uber what is the funniest
misdirect about it
yeah and it's my least favorite form of
comedy
yeah because it's devoid of in my
opinion is devoid of
the visceral reaction that comedy
creates
yeah instead of gamifying it and like
tricking you into laughing at it
i'm gonna penetrate you in a way yeah
that is going to stay inside i mean this
is very sexual
everything all right now yeah but uh but
i'm gonna
i'm the joke is gonna penetrate you in a
way that is just gonna stick with you
yeah and you feel it i remember you
saying early on somebody was like
crushing on stage but it was like
whatever is
the cute comedy or whatever yeah and
then you were like i honestly believe
the laughs are different when you're
doing like
what we do it's different and you can
feel it when you really hit on some [ __ ]
that's deep down
a feeling that people have you feel the
difference in the last they react too
different even after the show the
reaction is like you just spoke to
someone's soul
yeah and um it's just
yeah i had an experience so uh last week
i mentioned like i don't think i've
seen much of patrice i just saw like
clips on youtube prior to that
and i knew that the doc was coming out
so i was like you know what let me make
sure
to either watch or listen to some of the
stand up so i downloaded uh mr p
[ __ ] testing oh my god i've never
laughed that hard on a
flight you know my laugh yeah yeah
you can hear me over the [ __ ] loud
ass plane like i was dying his [ __ ] was
hilarious
so good i listened to that the day or
whatever
the african guy in audience oh my
goodness i look like the most wobble
person
back when i lived in brooklyn listen to
that cd just walking on the street
[ __ ]
cackling laughing bent over like i look
like
such a [ __ ] like you can't help it it's
[ __ ] hilarious
where did you imagine him doing that
show in your head where is he performing
it in your head
in my head it's really small it's a very
small room because you can hear
i know the exact room that it's not but
in my head
i have a different room same i don't dc
improv i zoom
is it dc improv where do you imagine dc
says dc yeah but i imagine like uh
oh i see i was gonna say an improv
that's my home club maybe you imagine
your home club or the the club
like when i was a kid yeah yeah i would
go to the [ __ ] dallas improv yeah
i imagine like the small room in the
cellar like
yeah because you can just one here
everyone and it's like
the laughs are [ __ ] easy that's what
patrice's thing is there's
nothing like patrice live there's
something we saw we saw them together
right we saw them together comics comedy
club and it was like revolutionary for
me because it was the first person i
felt like was
i don't know i felt like was doing
comedy in the way that like i i
related to the world and i tried to talk
about the world and
and i just i just loved the fact that he
was so
fine being wrong but he was okay
with it being wrong he knew he was being
wrong but it was how he felt
each joke is how i feel yeah right like
he was talking about like oh god what
was he saying like about diabetes or
some [ __ ] about that yeah and then he
was walking down the aisle
he's just walking down the island
grocery store and he saw these uh double
stuffed
uh vanilla oreos yeah i'm looking at
these cookies like
who needs a foot
but like bro there's not it's not
necessarily clever
it's not like misdirecting it is a
little bit of a misdirection
right but it's not but it's it's not
tada it is
a [ __ ] visceral feeling he he is not
afraid of what he feels
so many people doing comedy they're
doing comedy based on what they think
the audience will feel are okay is okay
yeah and i first of all i never was down
with that and i
admired how much he was willing to go up
there and say how he [ __ ] felt
and regardless of the reaction a lot of
times it didn't do well for him
[ __ ] would bomb piss people off
people walk out the show
but it was what he felt and if you're
saying what you feel and you bomb it
i promise you it's so much better when
you
[ __ ] lie up there and there's been
jokes that i [ __ ]
i was up there and i lied i was like
this would probably be the funny joke or
this will get a reaction and when those
jokes bomb dude you feel like a [ __ ]
failure
yeah i tap dance for you and you guys
didn't like it
those are yeah yeah those are the brutal
ones
oh bombs are never fun those are the
worst bumps
i can handle a bomb if i know because i
feel like i saw it it's
actually what he talked about when he
tried to tap dance for the industry and
then didn't get where he wanted to go
yeah
it's just on a much larger scale for him
but in a show you're like
yo i i sold out and you still don't like
me [ __ ] you [ __ ] me nothing i hate
myself
more than i hate you [ __ ] the worse i
mean when you bomb
but like you're tapped into your
feelings yeah
you can understand their reaction
yeah i know what i'm saying is [ __ ] up
yeah i know that you guys are reacting
this way because it's hard to say this
publicly yeah
i gotta get better at getting you guys
comfortable enough
to say it yeah where you guys don't
react like this
but this is how i feel and you [ __ ]
know it and you feel this way too
yeah and i will still sometimes bail out
of that earlier than i want to
i'm actually proud of myself if i'll do
a patrician and the whole thing is like
that
and if you can win them at the end it's
the greatest it's the [ __ ] greatest
one is like i know you're not into it
i'm staying here and i'm gonna get you
on board and they appreciate that
an audience appreciates it yeah it's the
same thing about what we were saying
before about um
[Music]
fraudulence yeah honesty
if they know you believe what you're
saying they get on board
and once they start fee and once they
start understanding like oh this is what
he feels
that's why i hate when people throw out
the devil's advocate
i don't hate it i'm fine with it
criticize whoever you want but like what
bothers me a little bit about the
devil's advocate [ __ ] is like
when people go oh he's just devil's
advocate it's like
nah you're too [ __ ] to admit how you
feel
don't don't make a caveat
for my feelings i feel this way
you're too [ __ ] to admit that you feel
this way so you're trying to call me
a devil's advocate right because
it removes the cowardice from you oh
you're just saying that because you want
to have the opposite feeling no i feel
this way
i feel that kanye takes dicks away from
women
yeah that's how i feel oh you're just
trying to have a different take but no
no i feel that way
you're afraid of the way you feel
without
context that is a wow
that is true some people are just going
to see this clip like what the [ __ ] am i
talking about
and you know what i don't care i feel
this way it's good on you bro but do you
know what i mean yes
like the devil's advocate is such an
easy way to like uh
discredit or disregard someone's opinion
yeah
from the average person that's not
that's afraid of their own feelings
but i think that the reason why that
might happen to you
because there are some people that are
just playing devil's advocate
for oh there's times when we just played
devil's advocate for sure
yes it's hard to distinguish just the
shock jock person from
there's time hey we do both hey you know
what but and that's what i'm saying so
you're gonna get it sometimes you know
what
here's the thing and this is what is so
hard to understand but it's only
understood really in the context of
comedy
and it's more so in the context of
podcasts because so many of us are doing
podcasts now but like when you're on
stage
on stage should be a feeling environment
we're not on stage for the truth
right or the lie we're on stage for the
feeling the feeling is true there's
nothing more annoying than an audience
member fact-checking you it's like shut
the [ __ ] up yeah this is outside of
facts this is facts no feelings that's
where the
the ethos of this yeah so like when when
i'm saying this [ __ ] about belichick
being a trash coach
he might objectively be a good coach
yeah but my
feeling i have this feeling like he's
whack yeah he's whack and i'm telling
you that's how i
feel and i'm gonna justify whatever
goofy ass ways i'm gonna justify it but
i do have that feeling
you know what i mean yeah but you're
right 100 sometimes we just make an
absurd
of course yeah but there's no rules to
this [ __ ] feelings no facts we are we
are a feeling podcast we are feeling
comics
we are emotional people that's what we
ride on but
uh jim norton said the most brilliant
thing the brilliant description of
patrice
he goes patrice lived his life like a
movie was being made about him
and he was going to have to watch it
with all of his closest friends
and they will call out all of his they
would call out all his [ __ ] so in
every interaction he was with somebody
he would call them out on being phony
because if he didn't
when he watched this movie of his life
with his boys later oh you're gonna let
him talk to you like that
you're gonna okay yeah you see what i'm
saying like robinson also had a profound
ass thing where he was like
some of that is feet like they all
talked about how like what an [ __ ] he
was on set or whatever and he goes a lot
of that is fear too
you are afraid of not being good enough
when you get the shot
so you self-sabotage and that's what's
also really interesting about patrice is
i've never seen a more confident comic
on stage in my life
and to still have that fear it's just an
interesting like juxtaposition bro you
know what happened to me after watching
this doc
it it
it humanized him which was a letdown
i want to see superman be human he's
your superman he was superman
he was iron man you know what i mean
like he was a superhero to me
and watching this made me realize he was
a man so
a flawed man a scared man as well
and that made his death ten
times more [ __ ] tragic yeah when
superman dies
it was okay because he wasn't a human
being
you know what i mean like he didn't to
me i didn't build up relationship with
him i was too in awe
of him to build up a relationship i saw
him i met him a few times i was too in
awe
to try to build a relationship with him
yeah that's how high i rank him
and when i saw that i wasn't
sad when he died yeah because he wasn't
even a human being
he was beyond that you know so
when i watched it all of a sudden he
became a human being and afterwards i
was
[ __ ] heartbroken bro
you know what else they touch on toward
the end and it's something when we talk
about chappelle and patrice and i put
chappelle above
i forgot so chappelle i love for a lot
of his [ __ ]
after like for equanimity and for bird
revelation
and the other one he did with the he
saves but he rapes
but chappelle was still like tapping
into that patrice was still getting
better
elephant in the room was one maybe the
best hour special i've ever seen
then he followed up with an album that i
think is better
than that so patrice was figuring out he
had seen okay this is how i do
this comedy where i'm telling the truth
but it's palatable for you
and that's where i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
where it felt really tragic to me this
guy was still getting better yeah at 43
or whatever it was he had
really really figured it out now he was
about to hit another level and i forget
that
10 years later but then when i watch
this i'm like yo [ __ ] this guy was about
to be
and you think about what we've pushed
back against which is the pc culture and
[ __ ] if we had him
i don't know if our fight is nearly as
hard i mean it's just like
he's taking care of a lot of it he's
just getting bigger and bigger and it's
like what are we worried about he would
have got canceled
he wouldn't have given a [ __ ] though
people but i'm just saying he like he
would have been toxic
the most the highest level of toxic
he would have been that because he keeps
it just too real and yeah
aren't ready for that he died so we
could be great
come on thank you patrice
thank you my bank account appreciates
you patrice
yeah uh whatever so i would i i guys
we'll try to put a link or some way
where you can watch it please watch it
if you care about comedy and you're just
curious about this guy who uh
unfortunately will probably be um
forgotten in comedy history
and uh when bill burr i'll say this
yeah he will be forgotten in comedy
history but
he will 100 live on to the people he
influenced like uh we were just talking
a bunch of comics after a party we were
talking about like who people are
influenced by and you could see them
in their comedy you know what i mean and
um
most people don't know where i
come from like we could think of other
kind of famous comics like oh he's kind
of like a tell or he's kind of like
louie or he's kind of like this or he's
kind of like eddie murphy was like prior
et cetera
and um we were they came to me like yeah
i don't know who you i
don't know who you are and it was a
compliment at first because i'm like oh
that's kind of cool like i'm unique and
i'm like no no
it's patrice like this is that is the
lane
that is the the funnel that i come from
so
my success and all the other people
patrice influence is
a legacy do you know what i mean yeah so
maybe he gets forgotten in the casual
fan but like as long as i'm alive i will
give all the [ __ ] credit to
the most influential person i've ever
you know seen in comedy and the greatest
comic that i've ever seen
hands down man i wish i remember there
was one other line from robert kelly i
think i [ __ ] wish i remembered i
remember the keith robinson line stuck
out to me what was the body
i can't remember if i remember i'll come
back to it oh is it about uh him feeling
was it
uh insecurity of patrice's or maybe it
was toward the end he said something i'm
like god damn i wish i [ __ ] remember
what it was
the having the baby [ __ ] was rough i
mean that was rough
kept keeping the pregnancy test in a
drawer and his girl
saw the pregnancy test because he asked
his
well he didn't ask his girl but he was
like i don't feel uncomfortable bringing
a kid into this world because i don't
think i'm gonna be here for a long time
i don't want to leave you with a kid
but it is your choice but it is your
choice and you do whatever you want to
do and they ended up
not you know terminating the pregnancy
and like months later i guess
she opened up one of these drawers and
found the pregnancy test and she's like
yo what's this about he goes
put that uh put that back in there and
then close the door and he never spoke
he wouldn't even look he's watching tv
he didn't even look at him yeah look at
her stayed on the tv
put that back in the drawer and that's
the one time you see patrice not on his
emotions and his feelings that's how
much it [ __ ] with him
bro 100 great observation he didn't he
wasn't truthful about
what that was to him everything else
he's talked to his mom about jerking off
eating [ __ ] or whatever it was yeah
yeah but like
that i can't i can't deal with that
there's a
scene with his stepdaughter this girl
had a daughter already
and when she speaks about
him yeah it's profound she's like
he's the reason for my confidence yeah
she's like i
i have a big head i love my big head
because patrice
made me love my big head and he always
told me you nobody
you need to control how you feel you're
going to love yourself like seeing
that's what i'm talking about like the
effect that you have on human beings
if you live your life in a way that is
impactful
you he continues to exist and maybe
that's corny he's saying i don't give a
[ __ ] but that [ __ ] continues to
exist
and her and us and all these people
and i see i see him in bill burke
yeah you know but bill always says this
guy's
this guy's better than when you when you
talk about like
comics that are based on feeling yeah
bill burr is all feeling
yeah like he's clever but literally i
started punching the muffins
wham wham wait like that is visceral
feeling yes right and he is
these boston guys man best comics in the
world come from boston
but yeah he is feeling bobby kelly is
feeling yeah you know like telling you
man
there's something there well i wasn't
even gonna say first of all he says [ __ ]
like
we thought we would learn something and
then patrice had already figured it out
[ __ ] years ago like he was always so
far ahead of us but you'll see it in the
moments where bill burr is like
up there pontificating doesn't give a
[ __ ] how the audience feels
i'm sure he would have gotten there on
his own but i think a part of that is
also
that's patrice and bilbo always looked
at patrice like that's the [ __ ] best
guy
that's what i want to be yeah who gives
a [ __ ] they're not laughing i live in my
honesty i live in my emotion that's what
it is yeah yeah
yeah another thing i was fascinated by
is how can he
be so honest with his girl and
talk about her like that on stage yeah
and she love him the way he does
like that is she came into the game bro
she knew what it was
oh he kept it with her you kept honest
with the whole time
it's funny to see like how it was crazy
like mythology builds around figures
uh there was one story there was a
little bit of a letdown for me
the story about how patrice first did
stand yeah yeah yeah
had changed through time and this is how
you get
cyclopses or cyclops eye or whatever the
[ __ ] that is
like a cyclops started out as a big guy
was just missing one of his eyes and
then someone said yeah they're [ __ ]
these huge dudes and then this guy one
eye
and then three or four people you tell
that story to later it's
they had one eye in the center of their
head and they were 18 feet tall etc
and like the story that was always going
around about the first time patrice did
stand up was that he was heckling a
comic on stage
and the comic said well why don't you
come up here and do stand-up and then he
did
and he just started murdering yeah and
then he's that was stand up after that
and in the movie or the doc
it's he started heckling the comic and
then after the show went up to him it
was like i was just helping you out man
and then he was like yeah you should try
it out and then he tried it out later
but he didn't go up on stage that night
right
goldman talked about though he had this
like uh patrice had this joke that was
like i don't like being the fat
spokesperson or whatever but like a
jokey joke yeah
and then goldman said i came back a few
months later and he wasn't doing it and
i was so happy
that patrice moved on from because i was
like oh that's just not a patrice thing
yeah
i mean he's probably early in the game
but then goldman was like he was done
with that so quickly that's not what he
was about but it was such a great joke
it was a great joke but he just had like
fat people like
go like fat people like acknowledge him
on the street yeah
like this they do something like he's
like what's up brother
what do you want me to do but like
what's beautiful about that is it's not
again that's there's nothing clever
there there's no trick
you know what i mean that's like you
know found like a hack on our dna to get
elicit a reaction it's literally just
that's a hilarious feeling that i i
can't relate to that but i can see a fat
guy look at another fat guy like
we later
i don't know he's just [ __ ] this is
the best
you